my name is Jeff Nichols I'm a filmmaker
I have made three movies that have been
released and I'm currently working on my
fourth I've been really lucky that each
film that I've made has gotten a larger
and larger budget and kind of despite
that I've been able to maintain some
creative control
I write each of my films I direct each
of my films and I have final cut over
their edits so if you've happened to
actually see one of my movies and you
don't like it it is totally my fault
there's no one else to blame the good
thing about that is over the course of
three films I've actually been able to
develop a point of view as a filmmaker
it doesn't always happen in this
business but because of that control
I've been able to think about my films
and put something very personal into
each of them in my first film shotgun
stories I actually didn't know what I
was doing when I started it it wasn't
until after the film was finished and I
read one of the first reviews that I
realized I had a point of view there was
this review that came out that said both
the camera and the characters were
languid which is a really fancy way of
saying that movies really slow
funny thing is when I read it I agreed
and I actually I actually thought I
meant to do it I just had never been
forced to enunciate it before I'd
financed that film with friends and
families money and nobody asked me why I
was doing it I was just doing it my
first film shotgun story's follows a
feud between two sets of half-brothers
and the violence escalates it
essentially is a revenge narrative
revenge narratives typically westerns
action movies it follows a good guy
whose buddy gets killed or something and
he chases him and then eventually shoots
him or drops him off a building and as
an audience we feel really good because
the bad guy got what he deserved but I
wanted to subvert that I wanted to
subvert that idea even though I didn't
really know I was doing it and the first
thing to do was to make a film that was
very still very quiet
also that's because I chose to to follow
the lower-class set of brothers
typically these guys would be the bad
guys in the movie but I wanted to figure
out what they were about and humanized
them the thing about them is they're not
upwardly mobile guys they're like these
white trash redneck guys in Southeast
Arkansas and they weren't making
progress in their lives if anything
through their actions of the film they
were hurting themselves and as a result
I thought about the camera and I thought
that it should just be still they aren't
moving so we aren't moving and oddly
enough there's a tension in the film
that ratchets up and the camera still
doesn't move it's almost oppressive the
way that you have to watch it so I want
to show you this clip a little bit of
context this scene follows two of our
main characters after they find out that
their younger brother has been killed
and they're standing outside the
hospital and they mention a character's
name and that happens to be the younger
brother's fiancee
I get back inside talk to this person
okay
you go by Annie's mom I don't know yeah
well
somebody's gonna have to tell Cheryl
Hey
I see at all
that was two shots it was a wide shot it
was a close up close up breaking shot so
one characters in the foreground one
characters in the background
ninety percent of directors myself
included when that character turns to
look at the other one you direct focus
you would go down I didn't I didn't
really know why on set I didn't I just
thought it was cool but when you start
to think about it you realized that it
forces you to stay with that other
character and forces you to think about
him it's his point of view and he's
trying to take control of a situation he
has no control over so then that starts
to bring up this idea that that this
bigger point of view that you're trying
to make as a filmmaker this idea this
team it's all supported by this
disparate collection of shots that's all
you really have to work with and I
promised myself going into my next film
that before I started I would enunciate
this point of view and I would try and
support it through these shots as a
filmmaker you really only have three
things to work with
you have camera placement we don't
always realize this on set a filmmaker
has a 360 degree view to choose from do
I put the camera up high down low
far away close up next you have to
choose the lens wide lens long lens long
lens was the second shot and then
there's movement and there different
types of movement one in this there's no
movement there's dolly which is a track
that keeps the frame locked their
Steadicam movement which is a gyroscopic
device that hangs off the person that
wears it and it it moves in a very
elegant smooth way and then there's
handheld movement which is what you've
seen Jason Bourne movies and all these
things add up together to mean something
and to mean a point of view usually it's
a character point of view but even when
you have all these shots that are
character's point of view they have to
add up to something they have to mean
something so for my second film it's
called take shelter I wrote it in 2008
the economy was collapsing the
environment was going crazy and my wife
was pregnant I was very nervous I was
very anxious and I wanted to make a
movie about that so I designed a film
that followed a man who began to have
visions of a giant supernatural storm
and he didn't know if these were visions
of the future or if they were symptoms
of a mental illness that had been
running in his family and I was trying
to think visually how I was gonna
show this anxiety and I was sitting on
my couch one night and I was watching
the shiny by Kubrick and there's this
shot of Jack Nicholson and he's typing
at a keyboard and the the cameras behind
him and it's a wide shot and it's just
slowly moving in on him and I thought no
Kubrick's moving the camera why is he
moving the camera whenever you move the
camera it means something that means
point of view but whose point of view is
that there's no one else in the room but
it's Kubrick I know there has to be one
and then I realized there is one and
it's actually the point of view of the
Overlook Hotel you've seen the film the
entire hotel is haunted there is a
spirit that is working its way into
Nicholson's brain and that's what the
camera was doing I was like oh that's
really smart I'm gonna rip that off so I
designed an entire film around slow
creeping dolly shots so watch this this
is me ripping off Cooper
we mix that film here at Skywalker and
the first time I ever got to see it
finished was in this room and they were
right it never sounds as good once you
leave so my third film is a film called
mud and it follows two fourteen year old
boys who discover a man hiding out on an
island in the middle of Mississippi
River I knew I wanted to make a film
about unrequited love and I knew I
wanted it all to be from the perspective
or point of view of a fourteen-year-old
boy and so again I started thinking
about things my first film was totally
still stagnant my second film had this
very very metered movement I feel like I
had conquered movement yet and I thought
this was the perfect subject for it one
you have a boy who's constantly in
motion constantly moving and also you
have a film set on the river the
Mississippi River it moves about two to
three miles per hour
it's the most winding river in the world
very much like the story so I wanted the
camera to move very much like that River
very much like this boy I wanted there
be to be an elegance to it and the right
tool for that is the Steadicam I
actually think the steadicams the
closest we come to mimicking human
movement the way our eyes work in our
heads it's actually like a natural
gyroscope so I designed an entire movie
around this kind of movement
what are you doing what's all that same
boot print up in the tree just got
across the nail
somebody's been in our vote sheet let's
go
we got to go if you want to make it back
Shh glass is long going upriver hold on
up there I stop
who the hell to go I don't know
she you know that guy I've never seen
before
so you can see in that clip just
like the one from takes shelter not
every shot moves like I say it's a
combination of things it's like a
toolkit as a director I started to build
on there's still shots they're wide
shots but then certain ones move and so
kind of the older I've gotten and the
more that I've done this I start to feel
like I'm finally getting prepared to
make a movie and this last thing that I
have for you is new film that I'm
working on it it's with Warner Brothers
and they're really nice to let me show
it to you I thought it kind of made this
point which is you'll see examples of
each type of shot that I've kind of
shown you here some shots will be still
some shots will be Steadicam there is
actually a dolly shot in there if you
can tell but there's a new challenge
to my first three films we shot the
majority of things outside during the
day I shoot on film I don't shoot video
and it's really conducive to being
outside during the day but we don't
light anything it just looks really
pretty with the sunlight and I felt like
I had never conquered light and that was
my challenge for this film and there's a
little bit of it that you can see here
but this is a film called midnight
special and it doesn't mean much
description but I'm gonna leave you with
that so thanks
are you okay we'll be there soon why are
you wearing those goggles
he's with me he's my son
you know well you oughta watch your kid
yeah I got it thank you
okay you cannot leave the band you hear
me I'm sorry it's okay I shouldn't have
left you Oh
I'm sorry